not only that but german soldiers are
literally marching around with tiki tiki
torches honoring their leader angela
merkel as 150 major german corporations
just announced that they're going to
conduct the largest vaccination
promotion effort ever literally
regurgitating the government's talking
points trying to impose their will on
the people of germany so there's a lot
of history
let's pull this up we got this story
from the local dot d e this is a german
news source explained why is german
twitter up in arms over a torchlight
military parade uh it's not so much that
a bunch of you know german
you know
military men of some degree are marching
through the night with torches it's that
germany is also implementing lockdowns
for the unvaccinated
we're seeing in australia now this
outside of germany the internment camps
where you'll be taken from your home
with no due process and then detained in
a little tiny box where they tell you
you can only go outside to do your
laundry you can't or you have a balcony
sorry but you can't cross the line
you'll be fine five thousand dollars
so germany as daniel just mentioned
italy austria
all coming together and being like we
are going to mandate this injection upon
the populace otherwise you can't have
food
and now they're marching around with
torches does their camp have a little
sign up over that says like the like the
the vaccine sets you free or something
like that yeah
those are the arguments that that
government bureaucrats have been making
take this vaccine do as you're told and
you're going to gain your freedom
you're going to gain your access to
society back you're going to be able to
go to a restaurant and purchase food
well even biden is hinted at that you
know yeah
more than hinted at it he said that as
much and that's such a backwards same
kind of critical way of thinking that we
have to we have to first understand on
face value they're the ones who took
away normal life they're the ones who
take took away economic prosperity
they're the ones who took away our
ability to live a normal prosperous
happy healthy life they're the ones
literally implementing policies that
have created more depression more
suicide lack of economic opportunities
have impoverished people and literally
have stolen their wealth right in front
of them literally disappearing the value
of their dollar as it sits in their
hands the value the the value of the
dollar b is being extremely devalued and
and people are finding that less and
less they have the ability to do
anything that they want and every aspect
of their existence is being tightly
regulated and controlled by bureaucrats
who think they're god's ruling
the funny thing is this this uh it's
actually an old story it's from october
the the german torch story what was that
what were they marching about though
that was kind of weird
i guess they're no they were celebrating
angela merkel and this was a payover
they were marching to uh honor those who
risked their lives or lost their lives
in their operations in afghanistan as
part of the withdrawal and so this was
back in october this story at least i
don't know maybe they did it again for
angela merkel but this is the story on
the local and the funny thing is they're
march marching next to the reichstag is
that how you pronounce it yes with
torches in their hands so the funny
thing is when they announced that they
were going to be locking down anybody
who didn't get the the the uh the
vaccine
a lot of people were like oh there's
germany getting back to tradition and
getting back to their roots of you know
mandated medical procedures and then
this photo is actually old and people
are like hey maybe something's been
going on in germany that we haven't been
paying attention to yeah there was a
joke i can't remember who did it um do
you maybe when you guys remember he was
like
who was this who was i saw this recently
um
hold on i'm trying to think i can't
remember he said that uh if if he were
like the u.n whatever after world war ii
you know who this was maybe he was like
we'd tell germany you don't get to be a
country anymore it's like you you
started a war against the world like
literally trying to like nor mcdonald
maybe yeah i think it was nor mcdonald's
yeah he was like you started a war
against the world yeah so uh you don't
get to be a country anymore because look
what happens when we just like let them
keep doing their things it's a weird
thing but you know if you don't have you
know what i love the most about the
european union in germany is that we
literally have like two wars in a cold
war in an attempt to prevent the the
consolidation of power in europe under
one governing authority and then germany
comes along and they're like hey guys
let's do this union thing we'll have the
strongest economy your currencies will
all be devalued and then you have to
borrow from us and germany basically
becomes the dominant power in the
european union
i have a pretty lit friend on the right
who i won't say his name but who has a
whole theory that germany is the worst
country in the history of civilization
because starting and he's he's very very
catholic
starting with martin luther in the
reformation oh yeah and he goes through
every every 1500 years something has
come from emmanuel kant something comes
out of germany that is destructive to
the rest of the western values ending
with world ending with the green
movement in germany he's like i have
evidence that germany's no offense to
any of your german listeners um i mean
germany is the worst country in the
history of
of the western civilization it's a
pretty funny theory was communism coming
out of uh germany carl where was karl
marx from was it from austria yeah yeah
was it was it i thought it was german
the frankfurt school was that from
frankfurt i don't want to be you know
yeah a little dull i don't know i don't
know where they say it's the frankfurt
school is that is the answer that
yeah what are these guys doing exactly
now beethoven was also german
you love him very much this is the
funniest thing about like white
nationalists and like their views i'm
like yo like these bad ideas literally
came from germany dude like you guys
were just full of bad ideas oh i i i
think the white nationalists you know
don't identify with the communists but
i'm like yo
you guys you need to rethink ideology
because you have no idea what you're
talking about because you sound really
dumb when we look at germany and like
hey all the bad stuff like the extremist
ideologies of of that era
mostly came from like these places yeah
yeah bad stuff we want freedom
you know the people who came to the
americas we're just kind of like yo we
want to do our thing even if it means
like landing a boat on a barren shore in
the woods and just building right there
and like these people would get on these
boats and they'd be like well
one-fifth of these the people on these
boats are gonna die before we even make
it there and then once we do another
half will die before winter comes let's
hope we have enough water
you know don't run out of apples how
long are we gonna be on the boat i don't
know four months three months depends
upon the wind yeah what did they have to
bring like limes with them how did they
pull that off did everyone just have
scurvy and they're all like hunched over
when they arrived i can't imagine the
folks who did it for back and forth full
time the traders right hence the dutchy
dutch east india company being i think
still to this day considered the most
wealthy company in the history of the
world yeah but imagine going across seas
and you do it again you come back you go
back holy cow the amazing thing about it
was how many people they killed over
making food taste better yeah it's like
dude sometimes like when i have steak we
just do a little salt on it i guess but
man they were ready to like colonize
invade destroy burn pillage murder and
you know enslave did i say that all
because they were like food must taste
better cinnamon
saffron
black peppercorn man that was it my my
understanding is that black peppercorn
was like they would they would stab you
conquer the world to sprinkle it on
their food
i admit black pepper tastes good but now
everyone's got it on every diner table
yeah we are very lucky we are very
privileged and that privilege and that
luck is slowly being taken away
from us by you know a sinister group of
really bad billionaire corporatists but
you know throughout history
when you look at history they they not
only tell very interesting tales but one
common thread is always these crazy
megalomaniac people trying to rule the
entire world trying to take over the
entire world whether it was caesar
napoleon genghis khan alexander the
great hillary clinton attila the hun
vlad the impaler there was always a
group of of of of people that wanted the
entire world for themselves and i think
it would be naive to think that there
isn't another kind of person or group
that wants to do that today and i think
a lot of the crazy policies that violate
human rights are their way of doing it
of slowly
incrementally putting it on us without
us noticing that there is someone trying
to
have control of everything there's of
course competing interests of very
powerful individuals who want control of
a lot of things that's just history like
you were mentioning but i think back to
the movie the patriot because i love
that movie so much when um and you guys
have seen it with mel gibson sure he's
meeting with i think cornwallis and
they're discussing discussing you know
officer exchange or whatever and it's
like a trick or something but he but the
cornwallis is like we're going to
discuss you st the
cessation of the targeting of officers
on the field and he was like gladly when
your officer stopped targeting children
and then apparently that scene like the
british got really mad like the actual
british were like we've never done that
that didn't happen but anyway i digress
the the point was
in that film they make the point that
during war they'd be like okay we're all
going to go out and march and kill each
other but spare the officers and
cornwallis was like could you imagine
what battlefields would be like without
gentlemen in charge you'd be chaos
this is the same attitude that persists
today the ultra wealthy elites are like
oh we'll go to war but don't worry if
you lose you're fine you know we'll
we'll we'll take care of you go to exile
or whatever we'll just kill all of your
all of your civilians and citizens and
then you as the wealthy and powerful
elite for the most part you're spared
except when it comes to more modern
warfare now it's like if you defy the
established order like they'll invade
your country and they'll just burn
everything to the ground like hillary
clinton we came we saw he died now it's
gotten like
just very straightforward war death
murder et cetera oh yeah or they'll all
they're like or they will cancel you
that's also another way
and and i think the more removing from
modern warfare we're moving into a
different form where i think it's
psychological i think people inflicting
harm on themselves after being
brainwashed and propagandized is an
aspect of this that we should be
entertaining because if you look at the
the kind of biggest increase in cause of
death suicide and debts of despair are
becoming more and more common and
they're growing every single day so i
wouldn't be surprised if that's another
layer another aspect of fourth
generational warfare or some with people
some people would say fifth generational
warfare i think we have to entertain all
of those aspects especially because this
concept of one person bombing and
attacking and conquering another
place has failed throughout human
history and i think there's powerful
people who are a lot smarter than that
and they have started to implement it in
a different way where it's not really
that obvious because if it was too many
people would resist them just like in
recorded human history they resisted
them and they weren't able to fully
successfully take over thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 pm and don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time